these children in the congolese town of
Borneo have come from overcrowded
displacement camps nearby they say
they're not getting enough food there
it's often straight outside looking for
something to eat I spend my time on the
streets with friends when one of us has
food we all eat together and if I have
something we all share it we have no
choice but to live that way
August amor hagar is 10 years old he's
one of many victims of a conflict in the
Ettore region which is killed and
displaced many since 2017 when they
started killing people in my village I
fled with my mother to her knee her home
we lived with my aunt until my mother
died just 70 kilometers along the main
highway north of Borneo is in Juhu the
Democratic Republic of Congo's Army is
pushing back rebels from the group the
cooperative for the development of Congo
it accuses them of killing civilians in
the nearby village of Kali on Saturday
night while people were sleeping
Oct bustling after we destroyed the
militias stronghold they trying to block
the main road and they ambushed the army
but with fighting against them and we'll
make sure they defeated their farmers
that have been in conflict with the Hema
harvest over land rights for decades UN
investigators say there appears to be a
deliberate attempt by Landa militias to
fall schema hardest from the region
these graves dug on Sunday belonged to
the healer between 1999 to 2003 tens of
thousands were killed in the Tauri
province the victims mostly humor the
phizzer these rebels are linked with
some groups in Uganda into trying to
extend their influence and the victory
province they mainly Massacre people by
attacking villages the army and police
this must stop
we need peace and unity between Eatery
people rights groups say at least half a
million people have been displaced in
recent years many have fled to
surrounding towns others across the
border to Uganda
the latest attacks by rebels against the
army was on Sunday just 15 kilometers
from Bonilla many more have fled and
local businesses are shot hundreds of
thousands of displaced people are now
struggling to feed themselves who are
living under the constant threat of
violence nor about a manly al-jazeera